welcome to this video playing
international master steroid from from
India to 290 the name in them
shyamsundar young don't know I don't
know him I mean who ok let's um player
Red Team kind of setup probably already
I expect d5 it's not done playing d5
surprisingly
yeah this is an opening that I have
played numerous times and tournament
chess um it's a gambit real gambit
giving away the pawn on c4 done and
often leads to interesting positions
with them compensation g6 is slightly
uncommon I can play a 4 here all night a
3 night a 3 however this be five
probably Quincy to now this probably
also be five
mmm not quite sure what is G 636 I think
I never got in the game I've played
really lots of times okay yeah
black-owned should try to keep the pawn
for the time being if you just place
move like Bishop g7 Quincy for why does
some why it's just better okay so Bishop
f5 now is interesting I go Quincy 390 it
should be seven now this I cannot really
believe in the combination of G 6b five
is some tricky anyway and down playing
the bishop to be seven here I don't know
this look some very dangerous to me we
take squint eggs b5 is hanging at I have
ideas like Knight g4 and 95 which are
really dangerous 95 e6 yeah it's really
close that 96 could be working should I
or should I play em Knight e5 it's also
not bad at all 95 Bishop a 6 it's some
girl it's a multiple multiple ways of
getting compensation
but I should have played one of those
moves first now that I think of it yeah
kasey kahne castle of course you can
castle now I mean this is a position
where white has some compensation for
the pawn it's no no question because
those pawns are completely paralyzed and
he's got weaknesses c5 and so on but
then I think I had chances to to get
more than just compensation
you know now Kim he's not threatening to
take because of the b7 my bishop it's
not not a big big problem question is do
I really want to play Bishop c5 he'll
probably i want so nitey for this rogue
a form
Knight takes is 90 form my idea
still not a force not threatened so I'm
intending to go to see 5 p.m. the some
compensation is based really on the fact
that this Bishop on b7 is just so
passive it only defends the policy 6 and
quite often you get the pawn back in the
long run but then you keep the active
position on top it's some very well
known structure from this opening also
from the Catalan and similar and similar
lines yeah this was a possibility I
couldn't really believe that it works
but he played it anyway threatening
rupee one now and 95 this looks like a
terrible structure okay it's attacked
it's a tactical idea probably I should
have gone to to some other square night
c5 bishop f3 bishop a3 bishop deform oh
great just great
if I go to any other square than be too
we probably is completely busted and now
it's working in some way at least ok B
takes a 4s just just terrible move ok
but it had this one tactical idea and I
didn't see it so everything's great for
black is there something else not really
Bishop a one maybe I can take a 8 not
being an exchange down
Bishop a one Bishop aid yeah maybe of
course it's like I just need to go to
some other square be one or whatever
yeah this is also possible but I don't
really believe in that so just move this
away
maybe tonight 26 I'm just I'm just
overlooking one movers here I should
play tonight b7 of course
hmm
yeah 97 yeah it's not not working in any
in any way not not in the slightest bit
why ya hey Sam this was just completely
completely idiotic I just need to spend
a couple of seconds here to avoid queen
bee to and black is completely done I
cannot believe any of this be takes a
for it's just just terrible but maybe he
can play c5 maybe it's a technical thing
now tween a three you can he can still
play c5
now yeah this is working can't play that
it's better than the game compared to
the game movie for white here I don't
have any any big problems but yeah it
always feels it's always hard for me to
accept a very ugly chest like be takes a
form but it seems to work technically
with c5 here it's working to perfection
because I stepped into this this
terrible diagonal so this is okay for
him actually yeah sometimes really ugly
moves are good if they are technically
justified and then it means it is good
interesting I'm very surprised I
couldn't I wouldn't have thought so that
this is so this is playable but ok c5 is
using the somewhat shaky night position
this means that I need to do something
else here yeah maybe you 3 or something
yeah it's it's very complicated one
thing that I'm thats really clears that
Bishop e3 was a bad move I should I
should play a 95 year on IG 5 so that is
forced to play e6 and something along
these lines here intending 95 deform
possibly deform yeah this is very good
for white I I need to provoke this is
sick smooth much better than the game
especially night x whoops especially
this is a strong IDM the combination g6e
6b five is just not good for black but
the way I played it he got a decent
position I have compensation but it's
not it's not really am something that
would refute likes idea alright thanks
for watching